it reminds you uh jamie off yeah your
youth in belfast because didn't you have
a
you
would try to go to the cinema well yeah
it's a big part of my youth going to
cinema but there's one
so it's bad like there's one time went
to see um me and about four of my mates
and i i was coming from a different
direction so we arranged to meet the
curse and cinema and the oral road and
um we're going to see this robert altman
film called preda porter because we
heard there was nude women in it
this isn't word got out there
this is 1994 so we're all
well i was certainly pre-pubescent i
don't know about the other lads but i
was 12 and looked about six
um anyway so i turned up late and the
lads have already gone in
and this woman were working at the
cinema and i said
uh oh hi i'm here here is he proud of
porter excuse um and how old are you and
i went uh 12. let's use it's a 15. and i
said
i'm i'm 15.
you just told me you're 12. and i said
look my mates are already in there she
goes what age are they
they're 12. she's they she made me go
and get all my mates
you ruined it for everyone honestly so
i'm like going down in the dark cinnamon
i'm so sorry we have to get out what i
was like we have to get
so we went to see the river wild right
with meryl streep by the way great film
um
but not what the lads wanted to be
watching
um but actually it ended up being a bit
of a win because riverwild finished and
when we were walking back out we saw a
porter was still on and the final scene
is just topless girls walking down a
catwalk so we got in for that bit
and we got there
[Applause]
[Music]